um sarah gavron the director i've worked
with before on brook lane um actually
arrived with an amazing body of research
and it was incredibly broad but i think
as someone who's worked on a number of
biopics including margaret thatcher's
iron lady i realized that you have to
find a prism in a way to try and narrow
not the range of the film but the
perspective sometimes because this is so
much material so when we came to look at
the software debt movement what was
fascinating was there were a number of
memoirs predominantly by um middle class
and the aristocratic elite um but i kept
on hearing this word reoccur which was
foot soldier and i thought that's a
really interesting word who were the
foot soldiers and i when i started the
photographic evidence i realized there
was this huge army of women and combined
with some of the testimonies of working
women it really made me prison in on
this and realized actually this might be
a great way to focus a story about the
movement so i think when we started to
find the character of maude who was the
central character of a working-class
woman we started to find a way of
navigating our way through this immense
movement that lasted you know 50 60
years so
um
uh that was really the turning point
and why is it an important story to tell
now why is it still relevant because
it there's so much to it isn't there
apart from the fact that it makes us
appreciate having a vote and what these
women do it is still so relevant yeah i
mean i think central to all our desires
to do in this film was to tell a great
story and it was fascinating to us to
actually um look back at history and
realize that there's a whole area of
history that we don't see through the
eyes of women so suddenly looking at
that pre-first world war period through
the eyes of this group of very eclectic
women um became really exciting to us
and what became important was you know
looking back at the fight that mrs
pankhurst took on was
reminding a 21st century audience and
the 21st century woman in particular how
hard it was to get our vote and how
important is we use it and that became a
very powerful
um
kind of conversation we had around the
film but also became central to the film
and the drive of wanting to make it
and it started us all talking about
women in the film industry and what's
your view how equal is the film industry
i think what's been fascinating for me
is working on this film has helped me
re-engage with my own feminism and my
own activism and i think when you start
to look at the figures across the board
not only in the film industry but
industry in general in the world of
business and the world of law we know
that the stats don't add up you know we
have the london film festival coming up
which has a real emphasis on strong
films led by strong women fronted by
women um which is really exciting um but
it still represents only 20 of films in
the film festival and it's even less
films that were made
by women last year so i think you know
part of it is creating the discourse
around the film is terrific and i think
any discourse around the film is really
interesting and important because i
think it makes us all aware that you
know we haven't reached equality and we
it's it there's still a fight to go
and you're obviously female you're
direct as female produces a female how
rare is that
i think you know the emphasis when we've
been working on this film is to try and
draw as many women as we can to the film
but also make sure that they are in
front and behind the camera and uh you
know it is rare particularly behind the
camera to find women and
um i think one of the emphasis on this
film is being looking across the range
and saying okay what you know can we
have more female focus pullers can we
have more female production designers
can we have women in positions of power
in the creative team and so it's been
really refreshing for me to work with
the complete female ensemble but i also
think it hopefully brings up the
conversation about how can we start to
create more opportunities to be bring
more women into the industry so that
they can tell their stories as well
because that's what we really need is we
need a selection of diverse stories and
the story of women in the past and in
the present is absolutely vital and it's
it reflects our life and so if we don't
see films reflecting our life then how
can we expect women to go to to watch
movies
and
why do you not think that there are more
women going into the film industry and
it is sort of a bit of a microcosm of
what's going on
elsewhere yeah i think it's a really
complex question i think it may be
partly to do with the fact that you know
we all need our role models and our
mentors and we hold on to those and i
think traditionally men have had more
obvious
mentors and have had more obvious role
models to you know there have been a
number of very significant male um film
directors of which we can name you know
from spielberg through to scorsese it is
harder to find the women they are there
and they are the women that inspired me
like nancy myers and nora ephron and
catherine bigelow and andrea arnold and
lynn ramsey but i've searched them out
i've looked for them um and i said i
think it's an element of um
we need to feel like we have more people
snapping our heels more women are
snapping at our fields
at our heels but i think we also
need to encourage women to feel like it
is an industry that's open to them um i
think it's also to do with the structure
of hollywood and the structure of a lot
of film industry that has been led by
men i think we used to sing ensembles of
films um films with an ensemble of men
in them
which means that some of the men can
have smaller parts which builds up their
currency to then put them into the
primary position of being leading men i
think often when you look at films you
might have one or two leading women but
it doesn't tend to be ensemble
um so i think it's a very complex
question about making sure there are
more opportunities women so that they
can be encouraged to come into the
industry
and and you touched on it before but um
why is it so important why do
a lot of people say it's only film you
know it's much more important that women
are doctors or lawyers or all of these
different things but i mean film is it
shows us so much doesn't it and yeah i
think i mean i think you know i think
you're right once again as a writer to
try and inspire provoke encourage
reassure affirm
um
you know push push a dialogue forward
and i think if we don't write the
stories that we experience as women then
how can we ever expect the world to
change you know i think we use film
sometimes as a way to reflect but also
to change and inspire us and so i think
i think what what's really been
interesting about the suffragette film
for us is the discourses that we're
having around it and it is raising those
questions about
why
why don't we have equal pay with men not
only within the film industry but beyond
you know why
is it that it seems that female
actresses have had to stand up and say
we're not getting paid the same as men
we're not being offered the same parts
of men you know i think these are
questions that you could ask in any
industry and i hope just by the very act
of making a film like this it makes you
also self reflect on your own industry
and where you're at in your life and go
okay am i equal does it make you angry
because the more i think about it the
more angry i get yeah i mean i think
anger i mean i think anchor can be an
incredibly useful tool
um i think i feel actually more inspired
than anything i mean i think you know
we're we're living in an age where
social media has made us engage globally
with inequality and it makes me very
angry and feel very impotent when i look
at the world and look at the inequality
across the world and realize i cannot do
anything directly but in a really minor
way i think trying to find those stories
of inspiring women inspiring movement
and actually
cast a light on women and the story that
hasn't been told which is the story of
the working woman at that time and these
women were voiceless they weren't
literate um i think we're just you know
you're trying to push forward and create
knowledge and knowledge is power so um i
hope that that's what the film can do at
its best
and you said before you were a feminist
what do you what does that um mean to
you well
you know i think feminism
i think what's interesting about
feminism is that i think if you'd asked
me four years ago i might have shrugged
it off i think i was i was much more
shallow
but actually i've sit quite comfortably
in my feminism you know i know i know
some great feminists and they're often
men you know and feminism just means
equality for the sexes and i think
that's what we're trying to do is just
get equality for women and push forward
equality for women across the board and
so it just means equal means equal so i
think that's just what any living human
being would want isn't it so um that's
what it means to me um some people kind
of think it's a dirty word
or have always and again there are there
are grumblings of that again and
why do you think that i think the world
is scared and they know what i think the
word feminism has gone through every
decade and it will continue to survive
and actually it doesn't really matter
what i feel about being a feminist it's
interesting that we're talking about it
you know and i think that's what's
important i feel quite comfortable about
saying i'm a feminist you know i have an
11 year old daughter you know i need to
be a strong role model for her she
certainly is for me um and so that's my
take on it and um but i think the most
important thing is we're talking about
what feminism means so if it starts to
raise those questions about quality of
play about diversity about um
you know the sexual exploitation of
women across the globe and i think those
are really important issues and you know
a playwright in in london will survive
whether or not you know anyone agrees
with whether she's a feminist or not you
know it will survive as a term
and merrill street has recently said
that she's a humanist not a feminist
do you kind of think
you know she has a platform she could
have said yes i am beryl streep is an
astonishing and experienced advocate for
the industry and i think anything that
she says is really heartfelt and
intelligent and i think her response to
that was well thought out i think the
danger is is that you know journalism at
its worst can be reductive and so of
course you have to think carefully about
what you say but she's very experienced
and i anything that meryl streep um
feels and thinks i'm very happy to stand
by i certainly don't want to be
reductive but i have to ask you about
this this ferrara in the t-shirts that
the cast
wore and in the last week or so saying
i'd rather be a rebel than a slave
people are saying that maybe they should
have known better do you have a view on
it
um i think we all acknowledge and are
aware of the sensitive subjects
certainly in america but it was always
our intention to portray the movement
of 1912 women led by emily pankhurst the
quote used was a direct quote from her
and you know we were living in a very
different britain today it's one story
and i hope there will be continuing
stories about injustice across the world
but the main thing is the stories about
inequality and i would hope
that it doesn't distract from that that
intention because it was always an
intention to actually make a film that
would inspire women to promote
inequality across the world for all
women